[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
we have neither for you today because
it's me interviewing francis and francis
interviewing me so welcome to the show
how you doing francis i'm very good how
are you
i'm good as well uh it's been a long
time since we've done one of these so we
did one
which we put out to the mainly list only
which was probably about a year ago
and then we did a trigonometry destroys
trigonometry probably
at our last studio yep which was over a
year ago now
well a lot over a year ago yeah we did
it it was probably two years ago now
so it's the state of the disunion
or whatever is going on now uh what have
you made
of the last year well we're all [ __ ]
aren't we get get the antidepressants
out
yeah just get them all out you're gonna
need loads of them no i find it actually
very worrying what's been happening
how we've i actually seen a nation
simply capitulate to the covered
regulations
and also as well how we seem to be fed a
diet of fear
by this government and as a result of
that we have started blindly following
the rules
even when the rules don't make any sense
like for example
why is it no as we film this now
in the euro 2020 final 60 000 people are
gonna be allowed into wembley stadium
but parents can't go and watch their
kids during sports day
yeah but the kids are [ __ ] yeah that is
true nobody really wants to watch the
kids no
look i'm joking but you make a very good
point and more than that we've got this
thing
as we're recording this will go out a
week from when we're recording most
likely
it's not just 60 000 people in in in the
stadium which
you can sort of start to go while
they're unlocking the country
but they've got these two and a half
thousand uefa
vips who are coming over from other
countries they're not subject to
quarantine
and they're just being allowed in and
that like yeah but they're rich
yeah they're and powerful yeah and the
truth is they're just better
absolutely they're better than you
better than me and they're definitely
better than you
so what you're currently seeing is a
double standards in society
and somehow we're still being told to
protect the nhs
we're still being told to socially
distance and it is deeply
deeply unfair and i feel incredibly
sorry for those people whose businesses
are being affected as a result
people who've lost their businesses and
their livelihoods when the rules
no longer make sense and they don't
apply
to certain excellence of society you
have to wonder what's what's going on
and what's going to happen
now boris said i think it's uh mid july
i can't remember the exact date
that we're going to be 19th july the
19th do you think we're going to be
unlocking again on july the 19th
i actually do in fact we may be even
unlocking
earlier than that in my opinion but i
certainly think we'll be out of it by
july the 19th because it seems like
yes numbers of infections are going up
but hospitalizations are going up very
slowly
very few people are dying today as we
record this
10 times more the data has come out for
the last few months 10 times more people
have been dying from flu
and pneumonia than covid so i do think
the government will unlock
the thing that concerns me and we're
we're again we're recording this
in the immediate aftermath of what is
now being described on our locals as the
black-pilled stream
where i dropped a lot of truth bullets
about what i think is going to be
happening
uh and just to summarize that maybe in a
slightly negative way what i think is
essentially lockdown is now a permanent
tool in the public policy toolbox
and what that means is whenever anything
comes up that
is likely to threaten some people's
lives
this will be pulled out of the toolbox
and applied so
uh the flu i mean the flu is being
predicted now as being more dangerous
this winter than covalent which actually
does make sense because we've all been
locked inside we haven't been mixed we
haven't been mingling
our immune systems are depressed yeah
so yeah that's probably going to happen
i've been mingling
uh but no seriously though like uh i i
think the
the the flu will be considered a bigger
threat
as we know the nhs is goes through a
winter crisis almost every year
and so what i think will happen is we
are now going to start to see
people demanding lockdowns they'll be
renamed into something like restrictions
or temporary
annual you know nhs protection measures
or something it will be
rephrased in some kind of orwellian way
and then you will have a lockdown almost
every time
anything like that happens and from
there it's very easy to see how you go
further and further down the line i mean
uh if we know for a fact like you and i
have talked about this in the past you
and i
spend a lot of time in london you live
here uh living in london
statistically speaking is as bad for you
as smoking if you live outside of london
right so why not you know we've seen a
massive reduction in in emissions and
pollution in the last 18 months
why not lock down to save the planet
you're making sure don't you want to
save the planet do you want to kill
granny
yeah i mean you do because you want to
get on the property lighter but
absolutely
so look my worry is this is that
we are obsessed with saving lives now
you cannot don't look at them
they don't deserve it yeah that is true
but we're obsessed with saving lives
which okay it doesn't sound like a bad
thing
it doesn't sound like a bad thing but in
the pursuit of that we seem to be
sacrificing everything else
and as a result of that you go well is
this sustainable
because i don't think it is how can it
be sustainable that we watch people's
businesses go to the wall
the people aren't working that we've got
all these people on furlough
when the reality is how many of them are
going to have a job at the end of this
the brewery in the streets on his knees
hospitality is on its knees
the you know the live arts and
entertainment is done travel
all the restaurants in this area seem to
be doing fine in france yeah exactly
exactly but that's because you know i'm
a philanthropist mate
that's what i do i walk in and then
you know i help people i help local
businesses yeah and they really
appreciate it the last time we went for
a meal around here they literally went
ah francis we'll take you over to your
table
exactly and they had no idea who you
were other than you just spend a lot of
money in this restaurant and i and i
called up and we i booked
for two of our favorite patrons at this
restaurant
yeah and then i called up gave them my
number they went oh francis lovely to
hear from you of course they did
but look we deviate but you know what
maybe
for the sake of balance we should
actually have a conversation about
uh covet and the reaction to it and sort
of looking over the last 18 months
you and i were well i don't know about
you were you in favor of the first
lockdown yeah i think most people were
most people yeah most people didn't know
what this was
it could have been far more deadly than
it actually was
we didn't know how we were going to cope
we didn't know the effects of it we
didn't know the long term
i mean you can argue we still don't know
the long-term effects of the virus it
was a sensible thing to do in the
circumstances
now actually we've both spoken with
people in the nhs
the argument was we didn't lock down
soon enough it was the argument and i i
know people who make the argument that
if we'd
lock down shut the borders early not let
the virus in
if you like or at a lower level and
protected everything then we we could
have gone full brexit
yeah i actually don't think that would
have happened though uh i i don't think
that would have happened and politically
i just don't think it was possible to
close the borders because
people have short memories but if you
remember at the time the left was all
about
closing borders as racist at that moment
in time there was a mayor
i think or or a politician in new york
who said go and hug a chinese person
he was in italy he was in italy there
was a man in the town of italian town
who said
uh hug a chinese person and somebody in
a politician in america said yeah go out
and enjoy the chinese
whatever um go to chinatown and have a
meal
so at the time i just don't think it was
going to happen but let me ask you this
because i think
in light of how we've changed our
thoughts on it given that lockdown has
opened up what we've just talked about
which is
the possibility of endless lockdowns or
lockdowns being a permanent feature of
our lives
do you think the first lockdown was a
mistake no
in retrospect i think it's an unfair
question
because nobody at that point knew what
was happening nobody knew what was going
on
it's an unfair question because when you
are confronted with an uncertainty
and a new virus you have to do you
you know you have to do what is
necessary to protect the population
especially when you don't have the facts
or the information
so i think at that point no i don't
think it was well the argument might be
whether lockdowns actually do protect
the population
well toby young famously said that you
know that actually deaths were
decreasing at that point well right and
and add to that the fact that lockdowns
also kill people
and we still don't know i made this
point on gb news last week which is
we don't know how many people lock down
skill and we still have don't no one
seems to want to find out
no which bothers me well the reason is
is because then these people
have it on their conscience that the
policy that they implemented
has directly led to people losing their
lives or dying but don't we want it on
their conscience so that
when people are making that decision in
the future they weigh both sides
people don't want that how many people
on twitter on social media
advocated lockdown demanded stronger
harder faster
do these people want it on their
conscience that they advocated for a
policy which
unfortunately meant a lot of people lost
their lives i don't think so
it's interesting and it's interesting
for us for you and i to be talking about
it because
if we wind the clock back 18 months and
think about where
you and i were in february of 2020
i was smashing gigs guys that's about
all you were smashing
at that time but but but honestly like
if you think about
our lives your personal life my personal
life
our work that this great thing that
we're involved with
are personal circumstances all of that
for us is better and yet we are now
simultaneously with that two of the
harshest critics of the government's
policy
how how has that happened i think the
reason why it's happened look
we did very well over lockdown lockdown
for us
personally was a boom time
it was a boom time it just was because
just to recap for people
uh before lockdown kicked in we were
doing what one interview a week we're
doing one interview
a week one live stream a week we're on
about 96
000 subscribers yeah yeah you know and
we went from there
to where we are now which is over 250
000.
and we're doing this full-time we put
four raw shows out every week
we do two interviews every week we you
know
uh we've interviewed people like jordan
peterson twice since then had the hying
bret
weinstein a huge ton of
really really spectacular guests and
that's because we've been able
you know i think lockdown gave us
permission to do remote interviews which
we
always resisted and there's a reason by
the way to resist them they're not as
good
as in person interviews they're not as
good as in person
interviews but it also gave us a large
captive audience
for us to tap into the fact was you know
they cup
tv production you know everybody was sat
at home
nobody knew what was going on then you
know then you had the
the blm marches and everything that
happened around that
so for us it was a very fertile time but
what
our platform has created is an audience
of 250 odd thousand people
more when you include you know the audio
so let's say 300 000 is a conservative
estimate
now for us and at times i must admit i
fall into this ban
i've seen these as just arbitrary
numbers but these are real people
with their concerns their struggles
their difficulties
and when you get these people messaging
you or talking to you via the live
stream
and they're saying to you you know you
have good thank you you're keeping me
sane
some people were saying look i'm gonna
be honest i can't handle your interviews
i'm just not in the frame of mind but i
really love the raw shows they help me
to keep me they help me a lot to keep me
laughing
and you think well look that's great and
you know we're both
really happy that you know we're keeping
people sane but is it the job of two
idiot comedians
to stop tens if not hundreds of
thousands of people from losing their
minds
yeah i don't think so yeah
so so i i guess what you're saying is we
are hearing that
a lot of people are finding it very
difficult yeah
we are and what you know and what you
get
especially from the comedy industry
where a lot of people are you know
middle class and you know the media
liberal elite if we want to use that
term
they're like well i don't see the
problem you know i'm you know
you spoke to a guardian journal you know
who's a very nice person actually
and she was saying well what's the
problem i'm sitting in my garden it's
lovely i'm drinking shabbily
peter hitchens made the same point but
the reality is
there are hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people
in this country whose lives have been
wrecked and destroyed by this policy
so why is lockdown so popular then
because
with the government have been giving the
population
financial methadone but the problem is
you can't be on methadone forever
eventually you have to get off methadone
and then you're going to face a brutal
bleak reality of the situation
which is we're in one of the worst
economic crisis
for the last however many hundreds of
years there's very few jobs to go around
you know how are you gonna get a job if
you don't have a job
and the real kicker is if you work in a
particular industry
let's say the hotel industry and you've
had a great career
and then you wake up and let's be fair
there's no jobs in the hotel industry
what are you going to do are you going
to be like fatima in that government
advert
and retrain as a coder if you're in your
50s and you've been a concierge most of
your life
no it's bollocks so covet is lockdown is
basically margaret thatcher just for the
hotel industry
yeah and the airline industry yeah and
the travel industry
and uh hospitality and live
entertainment
it's been a disaster and i think one of
the things look you know that you know
you could say that there's
there's been things that you know could
we have handled it better could we have
done this
absolutely but one thing i think we need
to take credit from
is the realization that we've been very
fortunate
it has been great for us but we never
shied away from the fact and we never
misunderstood the fact
that the for the vast majority of people
this has been an unmitigated disaster
when did the penny drop for you
[Music]
i think it was at some point between the
second and the third lockdown
uh i i supported the first lockdown but
i asked you this question and as i think
about it now
i am troubled
that i don't know the answer because
the first wave really was a big wave
yeah there was a tremendous number of
cases and a lot of people died
but the precedent we've now set in terms
of
this is this is really the problem with
with lockdown
the reason we've been saying the word
unprecedented about lockdown and
everything that's been happening
for the last 18 months what does
unprecedented mean well it hasn't
happened before it hasn't happened
before
is this going to be the last pandemic no
is this the last virus to come out of
china
no is this the last virus to come out of
anywhere no
right so this is going to keep happening
but
it's not going to be unprecedented
anymore so
for we've had sars we've had mers we've
had swine and avian flu whichever one of
those were sized right
the size was something different so so
all of them
and dozens of others by the way have
just been completely ignored
i remember teaching through through um
through swine flu
right and the schools were you know
there was no one noticed it really
right i mean there were kids off and
then but
you know we all just cracked on right
that's not going to happen again
no that's never ever going to happen
again right no not not
in the lifetime of everyone who's alive
today
will it ever be the case again that
someone's
quote unquote shagged about in china and
we are like oh yeah well you know they
do that
you know the viruses happen that's not
going to happen again
every time a new virus now comes out
there's going to be a minimum
of all borders closed minimum right and
probably some form of lockdown as well
am i wrong about that no no so
the question for me then is in setting
the precedent of the first lockdown
we saved possibly possibly we may have
saved lives we may have not but let's
say
that we did we saved lives then
but what is that pandora's box that
we've opened
that's what i think about when i think
about the long
when i play the movie forward that's
what i think about and you know a lot of
a lot of the thinking in this period of
time in covet has been very short
term we've been dealing with short-term
challenges
as you said yourself you know the first
lockdown was like you just got to do
whatever you can
sometimes when you do whatever you can
you end up
pulling out pillars that underpin
elements of your society that can't ever
be replaced again
and that's why i'm hesitant very
hesitant to say the first lockdown
was a mistake because we didn't know
what we didn't know
and it'd say and it in my opinion it
probably did save lives
if i'm honest but
the consequences of that over the next
50 years i i don't know what they are
yeah and i do i know and there's going
to be some
there's going to be some and and and it
worries me what they're going to be
to be honest with you well look i found
it incredible
that nobody well not i mean brendan
o'neill one of the few people and of
course brendan wood
was worried that you know that public
protest was banned
yeah even when the science said
transmission
in the open is practically
zero and still it was banned so you're
there thinking
hang on a second there's something
slightly nefarious going on here
and it was only with the women's march
when that picture came out
of that red-headed woman with the police
officer with the knee in the back did
everyone stop and think
hang on a second maybe this is wrong
yeah
that's very worrying that so many people
gave up
their right to protest and didn't think
about it for
one iota but look uh fair play to
brendan he was very consistent about
this and spiked in general
from the beginning and i laughed at them
if i i i made jokes about it
yeah about them being that like i was
like come on guys you know we just need
to pull together blah blah blah
maybe they were right yeah um you know
i'll happily publicly apologize to them
i think they were making some good
points at the time about the fact that
we have voluntarily given up a lot of
the freedoms
and what worries me now is you've got
these you know
people like they're not bad people not
you know dan hodges and tom harwood and
others
who who basically said we're not on
lockdown anymore the reason that you
have to wear a mask the reason you have
to socially distance
uh you know all of these that's just
restrictions it's not locked down
you know you well look why not you know
it's just a little thing
you know it's just a little
inconvenience yeah sure you can't travel
to almost any part of the world that you
like you used to
but you know just get the vaccine that
the government is essentially forcing
you to take now
because they're going to make it
impossible to live a normal life without
it
and to them that's not lockdown and so
that's what worries me is
that when we talk about the new normal
that's what they're really talking about
yeah the idea that these restrictions
are going to be done at some point is
right it's nonsense
i hate that phrase a new normal yeah
because what it means
is the life that we used to have and we
used to enjoy
normality is done yeah it is done
that's what it means in this country
it's done it's done
and i i find that terrifying
and for the life of me i don't
understand why other people don't find
that terrifying
where we as a nation have gone from
one where we see ourselves being in
charge of our own destiny i mean you
as a person seeing yourself as being in
charge of your own destiny
making your own decisions that's the
beauty of the west you make your own
decisions
you have your own opinions you live your
own life and you pay the price
and you pay the price you know and
that's life you know
cause and effect and we've gone from
that to wanting big brother to look
after us
big government to give us our money
you know so that we can go to certain
places decide how and when we socialize
if we wear a mask how we put how we do
public protests
how we congregate it's interesting you
saying this because you're generally to
the left of me when it comes to
like the size of government you don't
you're quite happy for the government to
be
spending a lot of money on public
services and stuff generally yeah
but i don't want the government
impinging on my liberty
and i and i don't understand
particularly and it's not just people on
the left
there's people on the right who are like
yeah what's the problem
and maybe it's because of our
backgrounds
you know soviet union venezuela that we
go no
this isn't a good idea why do you think
that so many people seem to be fine with
this
yeah i think the the lack of background
is kind of part of it
i i almost think it's like an abusive
relationship like the first time you're
in one
you don't really notice what's going on
if you talk to women about it they're
like well i just thought it's normal or
i did maybe i was doing something wrong
or whatever
but then the second time you find or the
third time or whatever
eventually you work out what's going on
and you just go the guy's an [ __ ]
you know uh whereas if it's your first
time and you've never experienced
authoritarian government you've never
seen that every time the government
takes your liberties from you they never
give them back
no they never give them back think about
this
before 9 11 right
do you remember what i was like flying
before 9 11. oh it was brilliant you
bring your own shotgun
yeah sit there yeah you know what i mean
yeah shoot a couple of people
you shoot a couple of people waitress or
whatever brings you a beverage nice yeah
occasionally shot a low act ball
that's fine it was great with the whole
plane joined in yeah
now now this video is getting taken down
but you know what i mean
yeah of course or before that [ __ ] some
guy decides to take shoes on a plane
they don't even
read yeah yeah now we're all taking our
shoes off for the rest of us yes
for the rest of our lives it's never
that's never going to stop and liquids
as well do you remember that remember
being able to walk into a plane with
liquids
yeah you know islamists could be like
you know what we're actually going to
we're going to we're going to get all
our money we're going to fund an
expedition to mars and we're going to
build a the the martian
caliphate and all the islamists go to
mars and we'd still be [ __ ] taking
your shoes off
of course and no and [ __ ] sipping
little bits of breast milk or whatever
just to get on the plane with your baby
that's never go that's never coming back
yeah so what makes you think all this
other [ __ ] is going to end
and the thing that i've found absolutely
infuriating is vaccine passports and
again people
who are one time i would have considered
to be intelligent
sane reasonable rational people going
but what's the problem
why not why shouldn't we if that means i
can go to a club and dance around with
300 sweaty other strangers like i used
to be able to in 2019 and early 2020
then why shouldn't we have vaccine
passports
if that means i can go and watch it go
to the theater and go to a festival
why shouldn't we
and i just find it it's not baffling
it's not upsetting it doesn't make me
angry it breaks my heart
because it what it shows is either
there's two things people don't
understand the freedoms they have
or they don't care about them and i
don't know what's worse
well it's i think it's benjamin franklin
it's his quote
that those who will sacrifice uh liberty
for a little bit of temporary safety
will deserve neither and get neither
or something it's i'm paraphrasing but
uh yeah if you give up
if you give up your freedoms for what
you perceive to be safety then
you're never going to get the freedoms
back and you're probably by the way not
going to be that much safer either in
the long run it's all illusory
yeah well exactly so i think that's
that's why it bothers us
um and let's be honest i you know i
think the truth is
that that's a fight that we've lost
it's a fight that we've lost i i don't i
don't i don't believe
lockdowns will ever be forced out of the
of the repertoire of government
uh i don't believe there's enough
opposition to vaccine passports they
will
they'll just they don't need to call
them vaccine passports but essentially
you're gonna have to have a test or or a
vaccine
to go anywhere uh to travel to go
to public venues whatever um
and i i i just don't see that turning
around and look
i i know that people feel would feel
that this is pessimistic but this is
just the truth
and i don't think there's any use you
and i pretending otherwise
no no but again it's a way that people
have capitulated
the only way this ends is if if there's
a mass public
movement of civil disobedience which as
you rightly say as long as the
government is paying people
not to work self-employment grants
business grants furlough whatever
that's not going to happen i mean i
think it's something like 70
of people in the country according to
polling which we don't have to trust
uh but there are a lot of people who i
know they they support more walk down
uh i was having an argument with
somebody today about this on social
media
and i got that doesn't sound like you
know it doesn't but but by the end of
the conversation i
i actually got them to say themselves
that they support annual restrictions
for flu i said to them i said to him
look if you believe
that covert lockdown is what we need to
do
continually flu currently kills more
people
why wouldn't we have a flu log down and
he went actually yeah i do think we need
so that's how people think
right um and yeah of course if you give
people 80
of their wages and the chance not to
work you could you could get
you could get a majority in the polls to
[ __ ] remove the statue of winston
churchill and replace it with one of
osama bin laden
without any pandemic on that basis if
you paid them enough and if you gave
them chance not to have to
get up at 6am and get on this filled
tube
next next to someone's armpit like
that's not appealing
and i get it i understand that um
so i do think the only way that this
ends is is a mass
protest and mass civil disobedience like
every week
and i don't think that's going to happen
it's not going to happen i'll go to
every process that i can from now on
that's the decision i've made
and i see a lot of people who don't ever
go to protest doing that
they're going to do that but unless that
unless that takes on a mass scale
i don't think anything's going to change
and by the way look one of the formative
experiences of my early adulthood was
the war in iraq
right and there's one million people
marched millions of people marched not
only in this
city of london but around i was in
edinburgh at the time and there was
half a million people on the streets of
edinburgh
right and the war still happened and so
i i just i don't see it changing no i
don't see it changing
the problem is is you use the phrase
play the movie forward
not enough people do that and go right
so we're doing this now
is this sustainable is this way of life
going to be sustainable is it going to
work in three to five years time i don't
understand why people
don't ask themselves that question why
is that such a difficult thing to
comprehend
and we haven't even talked about
economics yet the the truth is 40
of us dollars that have been printed
ever were printed in the last year
in 2020 there was a month i think it was
it might have been july or august i
don't don't quote me on this but there
was one month
in which the u.s government essentially
printed more money than had been printed
in the previous two centuries
wow in one month now if you think that's
not going to have economic consequences
you haven't understood what i've just
said right so there's the economic side
of it as well which people seem
and you know what i go back to our
interview with mike driver which almost
no one watched
and he he predicted all of this if you
remember
he is a nostradamus he predicted all of
this
yeah he did and i was right i remember
him do you remember
the first interview and he was banging
on i'm like
come on mike yeah you know put down the
pipe son
yeah you know maybe we should have
picked up the pipe yeah
because the reality was he was bang on
the money about all of this 100
100 anyway so that's the good news guys
so cheer up it's all going to be great
um
but actually i think francis you make
and you know how much it hurts me to say
this but
you've been making a very good point on
this which is
a lot of this stems from the modern
attitude to death yeah
we in the west
have made death a taboo subject we don't
want to talk about it we don't address
it
we believe that our lives are going to
go on forever
and any sign of aging can be cured cured
we can you know get a facelift we take
botox we have hair transplants
yeah we go to turkey we get our teeth
done you can see this
in our celebrities with their weird
smooth expressionless faces
and why is that because we can't and
don't
want to accept the fact that our time
here is finite
whereas before we had religion and when
you believed in religion
well i'm going to die but at least i'm
going to go to heaven we don't most of
us don't believe that anymore
i think we're going to say most of us
don't go to heaven we go to hell yeah
yeah but most of us don't believe that
anymore so
we think this is all we've got then all
of a sudden this
plague enters our country we have a
panic
because we think we've conquered illness
we think we've conquered death
and all of a sudden nature has given us
a massive wake-up call and said to us
you're not in control you are mortal you
are human
and you are vulnerable and that for the
vast majority of us have been brought up
in this country and have been insulated
from illness disease and death
that was a wake wake-up call too far and
it induced
panic and that's what we've seen a lot
of it
i think people suddenly realizing
they're human they're mortal
that they could get they could contract
this illness and they could die
and not only could they die but their
parents could die
do you remember this was our first ever
interview with simon evans
where he talked about what are we going
to do it was the last question we asked
him this is before the pandemic this was
way before the pandemonium
was around about may june 2019 and he
said there's a lot of people in the west
being kept alive
with drugs elderly people
what are we going to do with these
people how are we going to support them
how can you know
what are we going to do maybe simon
evans one of britain's best comedians
did in fact leak this virus from a lab
to take care of that problem yeah
he might well have simon if you're
watching well done
but the reality is nature
or this lab or whatever it was
created a virus that is is dealing with
that problem
and we couldn't bear to see people
who are elderly infirm sick
vulnerable die in such in in such
ways because we've never seen it before
and it was too much for us and look
i just for the sake of not being
misunderstood i think
uh we we do want to protect people from
disease um and the nhs from being filled
with
with just so many people that it can't
actually operate as normal
um but yeah i think you're right the the
fact that we
don't have a cohesive explanation of
what is the meaning of our lives what is
the purpose of our lives what happens
when we die
in absence of religion and you and i are
both non-believers uh
i think still despite everything that's
happening
i think in that situation it's very hard
to
to have a moral framework that allows
you to act
with uh rationally yeah you know it's
interesting i remember
when the fukushima reactor exploded and
not exploded it got
hit by a tsunami and there was some kind
of thing um
japanese people in the 80s said
send us in to fix it
don't send young people to fix this
nuclear thing
that their lives are long and
they could live a long life i am in my
80s okay i'm going to get radiation
poisoning and probably die
but i've lived a long and full life um
and this idea that we would sacrifice
the young to protect the old to me seems
like
it's a sign of a of some kind of
perverse
mindset to me um that we would sacrifice
young people's education and we had
david mcwilliams on the show to talk
about the fact that
young people never recover from from
from problems with education
it's called scarring in economics um you
know
it's youtube so we can't get into the
vaccine but uh
the joint the committee the joint
committee for vaccination and
immunization
as we record this says that it's not
worth
the risk to inoculate and vaccinate
young people
people under 18. so there are risks with
the vaccine too
uh and the drive to vaccinate young
people
despite the fact that those risks exist
and and the upside
to me is non-existent really because
they're not vulnerable to covet
that is a very dangerous trend that you
would risk even a little bit
of the health of young people to save
the very old and the infirm etc
um it's a sign of of some kind of
perversion in our mindset to me but if
you think about it
our entire society is biased towards old
people
they have the money they vote yeah they
have the pensions
yeah well our generation aren't going to
have pensions i mean that's widely
accepted
if you look they get winter payments
they have been the beneficiaries
of the housing crisis
what are we doing for young people
lockdowns happened
to protect the old and the vulnerable
what's happening for young people
when we're not looking after them
they've been thrown on the scrap heap
let's be honest i mean you saw it with
universities
charging nine grand for a zoom lecture
and effectively locking them in
in their you know in their dorms and you
know
demonizing young people for wanting to
go out for wanting to see their friends
and you know for wanting to to integrate
back into society it was interesting as
well wasn't that there was a period when
the case number started rising and the
narrative suddenly became
it's all these young people who are
going out selfish but but but it wasn't
though
no you had nothing to do with young
people who who were spread
supposedly spreading it but the
narrative was that
um yeah i hadn't really thought about it
in that level of detail but there's
something
that there's something there that's off
to me
yeah that that is not a trade-off that a
healthy society makes
sacrificing the young to protect the old
you have to look after the elderly and
these are people who've
who who've given their life to this
country and they've paid taxes and
whatever of course you have to protect
them
but i'm just talking if you were a tribe
of 250 people
hunter-gatherers that would not be a
viable long-term strategy
no at all do you know what i mean
so we've gone against our nature in some
way in doing that and
and yeah that's a the brunt of this is
going to be borne by young people
it's not going to be borne by the
elderly yeah because by the time you
know we
lift we you know we lift restrictions
we hopefully get back to some semblance
of normality
who are going to be the ones paying it
off it's not going to be them because
they're not earning
yeah and you know it's going to be our
generation
and the people i feel most sorry for
imagine being a kid trying to get a job
now fresh out of uni or college
it's going to be impossible this has
been
a complete and utter disaster for them
well there's another factor that i think
we should talk about as
we've got about uh 15 20 minutes uh
which is
the impact all of this has had on uh and
this is very much in the context of our
show
freedom of research and freedom of
speech
and freedom to discuss what the
government is doing so
the who set some rules for what can and
can't be said
youtube and other big tech platforms
essentially implemented them so for
example for a year it was
it was against the rules
to discuss the idea that the covet may
have leaked from a lab as we know from
our interview with brett weinstein
it is perfectly possible and quite
likely that it did leak from a lab and
the big tech companies have now
allowed that conversation to happen he
was against the rules and brett
is likely to lose his channel quite
possibly as we record this for talking
about
uh various drugs that may or may not be
effective
to treat covered we've now seen as of
this morning
on the bbc itself the ivormectin which
is one of the drugs that we're talking
about
is being studied in the uk as a
potential treatment for covet right
so it may turn out to be that it's not
effective but it may be effective
and yet for a year and a half that was
not allowed to be discussed
so that essentially means that youtube
is now
telling scientists and researchers what
can and can't be talked about in the
science
they are now the arbiters of what is
scientifically allowed to be discussed
what do you make of that i think it's a
disaster for free speech i think it's a
disaster for society and
again not enough people seem to be
caring about this what about david
fuller argument from
from uh rebel wisdom who had us on his
show and he challenged us
uh for interviewing dr sajar bhakti who
who had some pretty choice things to say
about this was before the vaccine
actually came out but he he
he knew how it would be made uh and when
you said to him will you take the
vaccine he said no because i'm not mad
yeah i remember laughing quite hard at
that not because it was funny just
because i didn't know
any other reaction that would be
appropriate yeah and so since that
moment dr sachara bhakti is known on our
channel as dr big balls or dr grossbalen
in his native german
what about david's argument though that
by broadcasting conversations about
uh you know treatments that are not
scientifically 100
verified or whatever or the who says
that we shouldn't talk about them
we are potentially causing people not to
have the vaccine or not to do this and
not to do that and
you know somebody could die as a result
i think there's a big big difference
for having someone like david icon who
was saying that 5g
causes covid to have somebody on
who is a chair of medical microbiology
at mines university
or to have you know the people on that
brett has had these are
reputable scientists these are experts
in their field having a discussion
but his argument is you and i are not
able to verify independently whether
what they're saying is true
and if it's not true people could die
do you think people aren't having these
discussions day in day out and their
homes no
but what what the argument is and i'm
just playing devil's advocate here
uh the argument is that by amplifying
the message with
our 250 000 subscribers we are spreading
it way beyond what
might be happening around the kitchen
table somewhere this is a whole purpose
of science you have hypothesis
you have people who believe one thing
about a virus you have people who
believe another
and then they challenge each other and
eventually the truth comes out you come
to a consensus
somebody gets disproved but the whole
purpose
and the whole process of science is
that's how it works
and suddenly we're going no you can't
say this you can't say that
but what happens if one of these long
voices is correct
they've been cases right away from you
know you know to
take the incident you know the
whistleblowers for instance when um
thalidomide you know everybody thought
methilidamide was a miracle drug
there was a few lime voices going oh
hang on this is good this is going to
win badly
what do we just silence those people
you need the lone voice you need the
critic
you need the whistleblower they might be
wrong
but it doesn't mean that we can't have
hypothesis
and our beliefs challenged because if we
do then we're living in a police state
aren't we
well i mean i think your point about the
way science works is absolutely true
like
as i've said before both my parents are
scientists my dad actually worked in the
soviet union
making viruses and making vaccines uh
and you know we had books in our house
about all sorts of crazy and strange
hypotheses
that turned out to be true or untrue or
whatever but that's the process of
science
you look at the fact you look at the
hypothesis you investigate it you test
it
experimentally and then most of the time
it turns out that what you thought was
wrong
but the discussion around it may often
produce something that's valuable anyway
and the other thing that i think worries
me is
you know we had brett on the show and as
we speak he he's just done
an interview with joe rogan and so we
weren't able to get him back and have
the unfiltered conversation that we
wanted to because
he had to reschedule but what if
what if most of it what if most of what
he's saying is not true
but five percent is yeah what if
let's say i'm not saying this is true
just to be clear because
i don't know but what if
the vaccine is just a little bit more
dangerous than we're being told
yeah just a little bit it's only gonna
let's say
cause complications including death for
an extra
i don't know five percent more people
than than we thought
shouldn't people know that isn't that
isn't not knowing that gonna kill people
of course so to me this argument
by is about how well if you've talked to
this person and they say this
people will die well people will also
die if we don't talk to him potentially
so this very simplistic narrative i i
sort of i
i play back our interview with david on
his show and i i start to think that
maybe we gave in a little bit too much
to this idea
that it's on us to not have
conversations that could have an impact
somewhere down the line because
i think at the time i was also not
thinking about the impact of not having
the conversation
do you know what i mean yeah it's it's a
complicated thing man but but it's like
jordan peterson was saying you know the
the modern world and modern technology
has unlocked
a thing that is way more complex than we
can understand
just like the printing press did i mean
the printing press essentially caused
two
200 years of religious warfare
the correct that tore europe apart and
eventually you could argue
to some extent led to the creation of
the united states and whatever gradually
over time it was part of the process
um did it destroy people with facts and
logic
it actually did believe it or not and so
social media modern technology it's kind
of like
a nuclear printing press it's it's like
times on crack it's a printing press on
crack and so
this is a conversation and a debate that
needs to be had
i don't um i don't covet as devastated
uh i don't think we can just say well
look
everything should be everywhere and
anything should be discussed without any
rules at all
i don't think so i don't think you know
people saying we should go and burn down
5g master whatever should be on youtube
but then where do you set that line and
i i don't really have an answer
i think if somebody is an expert in
their field
they should be allowed to talk but what
if they're not an expert in their field
what if they are just someone who for
some reason like brett weinstein he's
not
an epidemiologist or virologist he's an
evolutionary biologist
so theoretically you could argue he's
not an expert on this stuff
but he's hosted conversations with
people who are so we
that doesn't mean that we are experts on
it i think we are
yeah me and you well you're going to get
all your covered updates from us going
forward
yeah uh have a different we've got
another let's say 10-15 minutes
um is there anything else you want to
talk about
the thing that i find worrying is
how big tech censorship is essentially
eroding freedom of speech
and again people aren't worried about it
we saw it with trump we saw it with
hunter biden
and now we're seeing it with kobe but
see francis you say that though and
i'm going to have a go at here because
you weren't worried about
that story with hunter biden when i told
you about initially either because
because it's all it's all like this [ __ ]
that we can't do anything about
when it happened i came in into this
rare room and i said to you an ant on
both like
this is one of the biggest stories ever
and you were like yeah okay what's for
breakfast
and then most other people also react
that way to it
because they feel like there's nothing
they can do so maybe from your own
psychological
like health point of view maybe not
giving a [ __ ] about all the stuff is the
right decision
you know i think about my grandad who
who's who's he
he died many years ago but like all he
wanted to do in his life
was have a farm grow vegetables
uh have chickens have grandkids that he
could feed the chickens to
you know and and just do that and he's
the happiest man i've ever met he was
the happiest man
i'm not as happy as my grandfather
worrying about all this [ __ ]
maybe that's the right decision maybe we
should just go and live on a farm
yeah but ultimately what will happen
with this will affect you
look at lockdowns that will affect
people on the farm eventually
and that part of that is dictated to
what's happening online
if but if there's a massive pushback to
what's happening on
to what is happening online that will
affect government's decision
we've seen that we've seen how things
and movements and organizations online
have affected people
in the real world so what we're just not
going to have this conversation
we're going to strangle it right at the
source and if we continue to do that
i really think we're done i think we're
done
and i find that really worrying i find
it just
baffling and again heartbreaking and
what do you mean when you say we're done
because we have lost our ability to
challenge
we've lost our ability to discuss we've
lost our ability to share ideas
and we've lost our ability to create new
solutions
well what about we're having this
conversation here now
to to to certain number of people you
and i will both be on gb news
putting this point forward you know dan
wooden whose show i am on
regularly challenges lockdowns and talks
about it
uh there are other people with big
audiences you know joe rogan has just
hosted brett weinstein and pierre
i think corey is his name like
the conversations are still possible
they're still being had but like
agreed but they can't
happen rogan absented himself from
youtube
he left maybe it's because he got a
sweet deal or maybe
we're not giving him enough credit and
he saw which way the wind was blind
so he absented himself he left the
platform
gb news right you are not going to be
able to go
into as much detail as you can
in these shows here and we know
there's a lot more we'd like to be
talking about and we can't
because if we do yeah lovely ones
but because if we do we lose the channel
and that's censorship it just is
it just is and it's very very very
worrying
because maybe the government's right on
everything
but shouldn't they be challenged and
shouldn't they be challenged by people
who are experts in their field
who have medical background the correct
medical background look this is the
point i made
when we were having that conversation
about uh dr bhakti
why doesn't the government if if if all
if dr bhagti was wrong about every
single thing
if prayer is wrong about every single
thing which let's just for the sake of
argument say that
how hard is it for the government to put
out a
video which breaks down our interview
with dr bhakti or breaks down our
interview with brett
or breaks down his interview with the
other people that he's interviewed about
ivamectin and vaccines and whatever
and go well you are being told this
here's the medical and scientific data
to counteract that point and to
counteract this point
and and look you know what [ __ ] it i
mean youtube was attaching all these
covert warnings to any discussion about
covert
fine take our video with dr bagdy and
link that other debunking video right
there
i don't care if you run an ad every
[ __ ] 15-20 minutes
in that interview going here's an
alternative explanation by a
government-approved scientist
fine give people the information but why
are you suppressing that discussion in
the first place
to me the answer is always to educate
people i want to be educated
i want people to tell me what is wrong
with what dr bhakti said
i'd love to hear that yeah i'd love to
get
a clear simple scientific explanation
look
i'm not a scientist but i've got a mind
enough to be able to understand things
if they explain to me well enough
let's have that explanation let's have
the interview that we did or the
interviews that other people did
be the launching pad for a genuine
conversation
between scientists and let the public
see how science is supposed to happen
yeah this is the thing that's really
been
pissing me off about the last 18 months
is
this idea francis that we have been
following the science
is absurd nonsense of course it is it
doesn't mean anything
we had a story just the other day that
in this country
the restaurants and bars were forced to
put up these plastic
and comedy clubs separators between
different tables and different groups
turns out they helped covert to spread
is that following the science is keeping
people mostly endorsed for a year when
we know the virus doesn't spread
outdoors essentially
and it actually boosts your immune
system so you're more resistant to if
you're outdoors if you're exercising
and we were allowed to go out once for
months is that following the science and
we know vitamin d
if you have high levels of vitamin d you
need the sun i remember how people had
to go at me when i said people should be
allowed to sunbathe
and all of twitter piled up on me going
you were responsible you're killing
granny that's not following the science
right and that is the conversation that
needs to be had
but it's an infantile slogan there is no
such thing as the science
and this idea that there is consensus
between all the different scientists
is wrong they don't all believe the same
thing they don't all think the same
thing
they all have their different viewpoints
and beliefs this idea that we're all
following this one magical thing called
the science
it's crap and it's infantile
and it's stupid and it's immature and
you're treating people like idiots
i agree and people know this yeah oh
none of our rules make sense
yeah why is it i can walk into a gym
right and i wear my mask
and then i walk up the little stairs but
i go into the changing room where i'm
surrounded by lots of other little
people
and i get out and then i walk songs mask
into a room with 40 other people
and i lift weights and i'm breathing
everything out and you're touching
objects that they then touch themselves
yeah
and then i put my little mask on and
then i walk downstairs out of the gym
that's that's just the nonsense i was
walking down in the park the other day
somebody had cordoned off a log
[Laughter]
there was hazard tape around the log
that we're going to go and touch the log
and dive
you know what one-way systems in a
supermarket
well like the virus is going to go all
right yeah sorry i have to go
up this way in order to get to the fruit
and vegetable in order to infect people
there
yeah or or you walk into a restaurant
you wear a mask you get to your table
virus stops working when you're sitting
down
yeah it just operates at a higher level
exactly
you know so i'm going to regret asking
this question for answers because
uh this is not a question that you
should ever be asked but are you
optimistic about anything no the future
no no look there are some good things
that's going to be coming out of this
look number one
we've all had a child you know in the
words of original d hunter we've all
been sent to our bedrooms to think about
what we've done
and some good is going to be coming out
of that we've had moments of
self-reflection
i think we've realized that the way we
had of working our methods and our
manners of working were pretty much
unsustainable the idea really that for
the vast majority of people that you
need to commute into work every day
i mean it belongs in the victorian times
there's a lot of people who can
do two days at work in the office three
days at home
you don't need to be in work all the
time all day every day
but i think the problem is as you said
yourself
the cat's now out of the bag we've done
this we've set a precedent
and we're going to be able to do it
again and any time
the only hs is in danger of being
overwhelmed which is
every winter you've got to be aware
humans act in their own self-interest
are you going to want to be the
politician who let the nhs become
overwhelmed
do you want to be that person because
there's always going to be one story in
the mail
you know little girl had leukemia blah
blah blah contracted flew and died
right something like that which is
obviously awful of course it is no one's
going to advocate that it's
heartbreaking
for her her parents all the rest of her
family
but you could have saved her life if you
just look down
will be the argument no the fact that
you end up killing loads of other people
with cancer
doesn't really matter in that discussion
it doesn't matter yeah
because you are protecting your own
reputation as a politician and they're
going to do that
because it's a survival mechanism
because
they're acting in their own
self-interests anton we're going to call
this episode of the show 10 reasons to
be cheerful
well i i agree with you um and i
actually
i i actually don't want to end on a
positive here because
you need to be depressed no it's not
that you need to be depressed but i
think you need to
i think the thing you and i have always
tried to do
uh with varying degrees of success is be
honest with you with people who watch
the show
whether that's when we're doing raw or
when we're doing interviews we've tried
our best
to ask the questions that we find
interesting
of people that we find interesting and
to have honest conversations
and the truth is this is how you and i
both feel
so for us i know that for a lot of
people our show is
you know particularly the raws can be
light relief and it's irreverent
it's us taking the piss out whatever's
happening and you've got to and we will
continue to do that but
i also think that if there's a small
chance
to reverse some of this crap that's been
happening
which i i'm i'll be honest i'm skeptical
that there is but if there is
it's in everybody who watches the show
and everybody who comes across it
understanding what's happening and
writing to their mp
uh going on protest whatever it is
that that's going to prevent this from
rolling and getting even worse which is
where it's going and we've got to level
with people about it
now people can take a different view of
course they can and and and by the way
i'm not saying any of what i've said and
i don't think you're saying any of what
you've said
because you think you have some unique
power of prediction
i'm not saying this is what will happen
i'm saying this is the direction of
travel
and i hope it can be reversed which is
one of the reasons that you and i have
had this conversation because
you know in a very very small way not to
pretend to be bigger than anything that
we are
you know making people who who think
that what we
have to say about it has some value
making them aware of what's happening
can contribute to that but yeah
i don't i don't want to end this on a
cheap jug because it's just the truth
it's what you and i believe at this
point you know and
it just is what it is and birds love it
and birds absolutely love it
uh not ending on a cheap joke well we're
gonna do some questions for locals which
we
are building up looking forward to it uh
but thank you for watching
and uh remember uh this is just two
comedians talking we could be completely
wrong
but we're probably not
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below